what makes for a great Seducer is very
simple you are outer directed so when
you meet somebody for the first time or
you're on a date you're not having that
internal monologue going does she like
me or does he like me am I dressed well
am I saying stupid things what can I do
to impress them no you turn it off and
you're outer directed and you're
listening to them and you're entering
their spirit and you're hearing them say
things that give you idea of what
they're missing in life of what they
want of what their needs are of what
makes them an individual you're
absorbing it you're entering into their
spirit and then you can reflect it back
to them you can give them gifts you can
take them to places that show that
you're attentive to them because if you
look at how we are in our day-to-day
life normally people never pay us
attention they're always so
self-absorbed they're never thinking
about us the times where you get the
sense that people are actually
interested in who you are as an
individual is pretty rare